Some breaking news tonight.
The former
president has missed a legal deadline
to turn documents over to the House
January six select committee.
Senator Murray has latest, joins us now.
What do we know, sir?
Well,
the committee
just put out a statement
saying that they have heard
from the former president
and his counsel
and essentially
they are giving him
a little bit more time
to begin producing these documents.
They said
we have informed
Trump's counsel that he must begin
producing records
no later than next week,
and he remains under subpoena
for testimony starting on November 14.
So look,
in the past with other witnesses,
the committee has been willing
to push these document deadlines back.
What is key is to have some engagement
going on behind the scenes.
And it seems like,
at least at this point,
this is what's happening, Anderson.
So what is the committee's next move?
And what happens?
So now we wait to see how this plays out.
You know, the committee said
by next week,
the Trump team has to start
producing documents.
So we'll see
if there is some good faith effort
by the Trump team
to hand over some documents
or to at least say,
you know,
we can give you these documents,
but we have privilege concerns
about these others.
Or we may see them continuing
to try to delay, delay, delay.
You know,
we don't know if the Trump team
is going to try to be
in any way
cooperative with this committee
or if they could ultimately try
to file a lawsuit
or something like that
and essentially kick
the can down the road
because they expect the committee's work
to expire early on in January.
We've asked the Trump team
repeatedly today
how they're going to play all of this,
and we have yet to hear back from them
Anderson. Sir Murray, appreciate it.
Thank you.
Today's seen in The New York
Times and others, including Axios,
which broke the story,
are reporting
that the former president
could announce
another run sometime on
or around the 14th of this month.
Sources familiar with the matter
telling CNN that some of his top aides
consider this timeframe ideal
if Republicans do well on Tuesday.
As for the once and perhaps
future candidate,
here's what he said
yesterday at a rally in Iowa.
I will very, very, very
probably do it again. Okay.
Very angry.
Get ready.
That's all I'm telling you very soon.
Joining us now, CNN political analyst,
New York Times senior
political correspondent Maggie Haberman.
She is, of course,
the bestselling
author of the remarkable book
Confidence Man
The Making of Donald Trump
and the Breaking of America.
So, Maggie, how real is
I mean, this is happening. This is real.
What are you hearing?
It It sure seems, though, Anderson.
Look, with Donald Trump,
you never want to say it's an absolute.
Jonathan Swan of Vaccines
was careful not to.
But I have been hearing
from multiple people
that it's likely
to be that week of November 14th.
They considered an ideal time,
as you said,
because it would be right
after the midterms.
He had been talking about announcing
before the midterms
that really worried a lot of Republicans
who tried to talk him out of it
through various methods, telling him
he would be,
you know, blamed if they lost.
Remember,
he loses some things
by doing this, Anderson.
What he thinks he gains
is some protection
from Justice Department investigations
and he tries to forestall
the rest of the field,
especially in a week
that Mike Pence,
his book is coming out when he loses
is the ability
to use his outside groups
to pay for legal bills.
The clock starts on his hard
dollar fundraising
and hard dollar spending.
So it's not without risks.
But, you know,
he has been out of the limelight
in a way that he can't stand.
And I think that's a big piece of this.
Is that what I mean is that would tip
the scale, you think?
I think would tip the scale.
Is always with him
getting attention is the biggest deal.
I think that wanting to freeze the field
and wanting to send a signal
to the Justice Department
that he is going to make it as hard
as possible on them publicly
should they move ahead
with any kind of indictment of him
or in Georgia
of any will as investigation.
That's a state investigation.
I think that all of these are factors
I don't think one necessarily outweighs
the other,
but I think that he has always thought
that getting in sooner rather than later
made more sense.
Do you know
I mean,
do you have a sense of what his campaign
will look like at this stage or I mean,
is it going to be these big rallies?
Does he have staff?
It's a really good question.
And the answer on staff
is it's pretty lean right now.
And, you know, folks around
him will say that's by design
because they consider 20, 20
to be fairly bloated.
But it's also frankly
reflecting the reality that so far
and in some cases it's
because people are tied up
with the midterms.
In some cases,
there are people who are very leery
of getting involved
in Donald Trump's orbit
because of the constant churn
around him, legal and otherwise.
And so I think it will be small
at least
going into early 2023
assuming he does get in.
I think you will see some small number
of political events
happening after he declares
we don't know
the declaration would be a rally
or if it would be a press conference.
And I think they're looking at both.
But then I think he will resume rallies
the way he had before
I don't think you're going to see him
suddenly become a retail politician.
He's never liked it.
He's never been good at it,
and I don't think he thinks he needs to.
You just heard Sara
Murray is reporting that former
president missed the subpoena deadline
to provide documents,
the General Ethics Committee.
Would an announcement complicate
any potential dealings with.
I guess it would complicate any dealings
with the committee?
Well, I don't
know that it complicates it.
I mean, I think it's certainly become
something else that he points to.
I think Donald Trump
is running out the clock
because he thinks that the committee
is going to go away
if a House
majority is given
to Republicans after next Tuesday,
which at the moment
polling indicates it most likely will be.
It's just not clear
what the margin will be if that happens.
But his assumption is and his aides
assumption is
this is going to at some point
end in the Sara said,
I think they have to decide
whether they want to file a lawsuit
to just help stall that that motion.
Do you think he would
hold his announcement
even if the Georgia election
results are still undecided?
Well, I do,
but I
think that he will be under pressure
not to.
And we'll see what happens
if there is a runoff.
I think that is absolutely
a complicating factor.
You know, he is already being blamed,
continues to be blamed
for the losses in Georgia on January 5th.
2021 in those runoffs.
I'm not sure that anyone around him
thinks it's a wise idea
for him to face that again.
Do you think
he announces does he then get
I guess then he sort of
I mean,
I don't know how much coverage he's
been getting on, you know, a Fox News or
you know, big conservative outlet.
Does that.
Does that make him more more bookable
on those shows?
I think it's a problem for him, Anderson.
I think for a number of reasons,
the conservative media
landscape has changed for him.
I think one major reason
is that so
many of these outlets
have gotten embroiled
in defamation lawsuits
by election companies
because of the
the lies about the election in 20, 20
that were spouted on their platforms
or on their on their websites
or in their programs.
And I think that there is some risk
in their minds in having him on,
you know,
but he has very visibly
not been on Fox News very much.
He's not on Newsmax.
You know,
he is really relegated
to, you know, other podcasts
or some conservative radio.
It's just a very different world
than it was in 20, 15
when he first got into politics.
Interesting point.
Maggie Haberman, appreciate it.
Thank you.